[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a south korean zombie
comedy film called the odd family zombie
on sale
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the beginning of the movie shows us the
news about a failed experiment done by a
medicine company the company
manufactured something called neuncillin
as a cure for diabetes and illegally
tested it on humans but the experiment
failed and the medicine had mysterious
side effects on people one night in a
secret headquarters of the same company
a strange man emerges from under the
ground he is also an illegal test
subject who has been infected into a
zombie-like creature because of the
medicine the zombie walks into the
darkness and reaches a small town called
pongsan on a nearby road a car swerves
and stops abruptly the couple inside it
is catching their breath when a man
approaches them and hooks a metal rod in
their car it turns out that the man is a
mechanic named june ghoul and he
deliberately caused the minor accident
so he would get customers unaware of
this the couple let him take the car to
his shop the next morning the couple
gets the bill for the repair which is
way more expensive than it should be
june ghoul's pregnant wife namjoo is in
charge of collecting money from the
customers when the man tries to accuse
them of over charging jungle's daughter
heigl comes out with a butcher knife the
gesture does the job and the couple
quickly pays and leaves namjoo keeps all
the money safely in a box while jun
jungle doesn't even get to see it in the
following scene the zombie is walking on
a road looking for people to feed on he
sees two women and tries to get to them
but they simply dodge him as we see him
fail to bite people it becomes clear
that this man is unlike your average
dangerous zombie even the little kids
hit him with stones and tease him about
his looks he then comes across a stray
dog and tries to eat it but in turn gets
chased himself the locals watch him
running from the dog in confusion
meanwhile at june ghoul's home his
father mandioch is playing cards with
his friends as usual he hears a dog
barking loudly outside the house and
walks out to chase it away unknown that
the zombie is inside the bathroom
mandiock goes in and is attacked the
zombie manages to bite the old man and
runs away after on his way he comes
across high ghoul who hits him in the
crotch they both are then chased by the
same stray dog again while trying to run
away they reach the village's border and
meet high ghoul's uncle mingul he is
returning to the village after being
fired from his job in the city
eventually all three of them are chased
by the dog haighul falls on the road
making it easy for the zombie to get her
but just before he is about to attack
the girl a car hits him and sends him
flying to a field the zombie
miraculously survives and runs away
later grandfather mandioch returns from
the hospital after getting his wound
bandaged we get to know that mandioc's
only wish in life is to visit hawaii
someday he even has pictures of hawaii
on his wall and wears a hawaiian shirt
most of the time that night he sits in
front of a fan feeling abnormally hot in
the meantime the zombie is still being
chased by the dog around the village
high ghoul hears a noise coming from the
garage she and mandioc go to check for
the intruder and discover the zombie
hiding inside mandiock hits him with a
spade taking his revenge june ghoul also
arrives there and strikes the zombie
with a flying kick eventually the whole
family gathers in the garage and goes
full world star on the zombie they
assume that it is dead they look at him
closely and realize he is not a normal
human being suddenly the zombie comes
back to life startling the family they
hurry outside and lock him in the garage
min goon finally tells the others that
the man might be a zombie and shows them
a clip from the movie trained to busan
the family knows that the person who is
bitten by a zombie turns into one of
them so without mandioc knowing the
mother namjoo knocks him out with a
frying pan they lock the man inside his
own trailer for their safety the next
day mingul does some research on zombies
and finds out a lot about them he
explains to the others that a person bit
by a zombie dies and comes back to life
again they like to eat human brains
hence the zombie in the garage likes
cabbage because he mistakes it for a
brain mingle proposes to kill mandiock
before he kills them as the family talks
mandiock gets out of the trailer and
enters the house a stunned mingool hits
him on the head but is scolded by the
rest of the family after that haigul
names the zombie chongbi and treats him
like a pet namjoo realizes that he is
not really harmful but takes all of his
teeth out as a precaution the following
day to everyone's surprise mandiock
doesn't convert into a zombie in fact he
starts to turn younger because of the
infection his old friends see him peeing
like a young man and beg him to tell
them the secret of his newfound
youthfulness one of them who is getting
married soon offers mandiock a ticket to
hawaii in return for the secret hearing
this mandioc tells him about chong b
their conversation is heard by min goon
who plans to sell changbi for money
meanwhile mandioc packs his luggage
getting ready for his trip when his
other friends knock on his door it turns
out that all of his friends know about
chong b and everyone wants to pay to be
bitten mandiock happily takes them to
the garage only to see chong b is
missing then we see min goon driving
chong b towards seoul where he plans to
sell him to a viagra company on his way
min goon is pulled over by the police
for speeding the policemen recognize him
because they are from the same village
after talking for a while they hear a
noise from the back and reveal a tied up
chong b in the trunk both min goon and
chong b are then taken to the police
station the police take the tape off
chong bhi's mouth and see he has no
teeth right then mandioc arrives at the
station and claims chong b to be his son
at night high goon gives chongbi a
cabbage to eat but he cannot eat it
because of his missing teeth mandiock
gets to know about this and is equally
surprised his friends arrive there to
get bitten and bring their youths back
mandioc thinks of a plan and brings fake
teeth for the man finally starting a
business it's kind of like a lemonade
stand but kinky his friends are shocked
by the first few bites but they
eventually get used to it at the end of
the day namjoo keeps the profit they
made safely inside a box the following
day everyone who got bitten runs around
happily delighted to have their youth
back however a surprised non-jew finds
their box of money empty it turns out
that mandioc has taken all of the money
and has gone for a trip to hawaii
meanwhile the news about chong b spreads
throughout the village more and more
people run to jungle's house eventually
their profit skyrockets as trucks full
of people start coming to get bitten a
few days later they renovate mandioc's
trailer for chong b they even buy him a
new set of teeth which he uses to eat
cabbages one day high ghoul takes
chongbi to a barber shop and gets him
cleaned up chong b looks like a handsome
young man after getting a haircut he and
hai ghul have started falling in love so
high ghoul feels bad about her family
using him for money one night hai ghul
hears her brother mingul talking to
someone about selling chung b the very
next day she brings chongbi to a forest
and asks him to run away and live freely
however chong b who has also started
liking her and doesn't mind making bank
for biting people doesn't leave
meanwhile at mandioc's friend's wedding
the villagers who had been bitten start
to feel very hot they eat like they are
starving and act strange in general at
the same time mingul notices chong be
missing from their home he runs to look
for him planning to sell him for a large
amount of money a while later he finds
chong be right where high ghoul had left
him and takes him to the bus station
back at the wedding the priest asks the
bride and groom to kiss but the man
instead bites his wife it turns out that
everyone chong b has bitten has turned
into zombies chaos ensues at the wedding
as the guests turn into zombies the
virus spreads rapidly and people at the
bus station start to bite each other as
well soon the streets of the village are
filled with zombies as they take over
humans one zombie gets inside the garage
and attacks high ghoul she runs to her
parents asking for help just then a
policeman arrives at the scene trying to
solve the conflict but instead is bitten
by the man this zombie doesn't want
cabbage he wants bacon the family
realizes what is going on and runs
inside the house to save their lives
they shut the doors and windows and read
a zombie survival book that mingle has
written they misinterpret some parts of
the guide but at last create a make do
armor from utensils back at the bus
station mingool somehow survives and
drives back to his home leaving chong b
behind on his way he sees that almost
everyone from the village has turned a
while later the zombies managed to break
into the house and chase the family away
namjoo is almost caught by them but she
somehow gets her box of money and flees
right when the family hides in the
garage minguel arrives with a bunch of
firecrackers he lights them up and
attacks the group of zombies but doesn't
know the fact that he is shooting at a
petrol station he quickly gets out of
the car to stop the fireworks but the
car bursts into flames right after this
attracts the zombie's attention making
them hurdle towards the burning car more
firecrackers explode in the sky that the
creatures watch in fascination almost as
if they are hypnotized by it right then
namjoo's water breaks and she starts to
give birth jungle and ming goon dress up
in chong b's clothes and go outside
acting like they are zombies as well
they manage to make it to the car but
forget the keys inside when the car's
lights glow the zombies are again
attracted towards them the two freeze in
fear inside the car as the creatures
surround them to save them high ghoul
comes outside with a grass cutter and
attacks the group however she is soon
overpowered by them right when they are
about to kill her chong b comes to her
aid amidst the chaos one zombie moves
some wires causing the electric signs to
light up this distracts all other
zombies making them leave chong b and
haigul alone taking the opportunity
mingul leaves the car to get the car
keys from inside the house but before he
can make it inside the lights turn off
abruptly and the zombies turn towards
him at that moment the sound of namjoo's
baby crying is heard mingul fights the
zombies not caring about his own life to
get to the car keys the baby and nam joo
are inside the trailer which is attached
to the car
june ghoul is in the car ready to drive
away while high ghoul and chong b fight
the zombies to keep them back from the
trailer mingul finally manages to get
the keys and throws them at highgul
outside the family finally drives away
leaving chong be and the zombies behind
at last chongbi lights a fire causing an
explosion that blows up the petrol pump
the next morning jungle wakes up and to
everyone's surprise has turned into a
zombie the family locks him inside the
car and runs outside as they discuss
their next move the sound of someone
coming towards them through a tunnel is
heard a happy mandioc arrives from his
trip to hawaii with a tan oblivious to
what has happened to his village they're
confused why he hasn't turned into a
zombie like everyone else then the cars
radio announces the news of the virus
being spread throughout korea the
reporters claim that some people are
immune to the virus and they are also
the antidote to turn zombies back into
humans hearing this mingool gets another
idea he plans to turn mandioc's immunity
into another business
it is now six months later the zombie
virus has spread throughout korea but
the family is doing better than ever
mandiock bites people for a living
turning them back into humans chong b
has also turned into a human because of
the same method the movie ends as a long
line of zombies stand before the
family's trailer to get cured subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thanks for watching